so at the first sign of a stroke what should
someone do let's say you're with a friend or
a family member and you notice a potential sign
of a stroke what should you do first let's talk
about what are the signs of a stroke you have
numbness in one side of your body it could be
the face it could be even an arm or a leg
confusion loss of facial function loss of arm
function on one side loss of leg function slurred
speech trouble walking there's a real easy way to
remember some key factors and it's stands for fast
so the face okay so if you have the person next to
you that you suspect they just had a stroke have
them smile okay and if one side of their face
droops that could be an indicator because you lose
facial function on one side the next factor is the
arm have them raise both of their arms and if one
side just drops down that could be an indication
of a stroke the next point is have them speak
you ask them to repeat a phrase a few times
and see if they can do it if they start slurring
that can be a sign of a stroke now realize there's
a very short window to get this person to
the hospital so they can actually give them
some type of anti-clotting medication to open
up the clot into the brain so the brain can get
oxygen it's like a three to four hour
window so you want to probably call
now just as 911 as knowing what to do if someone
actually is having a stroke it's what to do to
prevent a stroke the most important thing is
getting your diet corrected so your insulin
is normalized so you don't have high insulin
because then you develop insulin resistance
and when you have that you have a lot of
blood sugar issues and you can form a clot
just with that condition right up the bat
so you want to do a low carb healthy diet
also you want to do a diet rich in potassium
a lot of leafy greens would be very important
potassium helps support the vascular system
and it can also inhibit clotting vitamin e
specifically the tocopherols are probably one
of the best antioxidants to support the brain
and free radical damage because what's unique
about the brain is that there's a tremendous
amount of oxygen consumption so you have a
lot of free radicals and oxidants going on
so you need a good antioxidant vitamin e
the tocopherol version is the best number
four ketones so if you're on a ketogenic diet if
you're doing mct oil if you take exogenous ketones
all support the brain the brain loves ketones
better than glucose and ketones are kind of the
opposite fuel to glucose glucose tends to create
more clots ketones can inhibit clots also fasting
intermittent fasting is very very beneficial
to the brain and also causing your body to
recycle old damaged protein and so one of the
most important things to support both your
cardiovascular system the inside of the lining
of your arteries and the brain is intermittent
fasting all sorts of magical things happen
then we have dha which is omega-3 fatty acids
omega-3 fatty acids not only thin the blood
as does vitamin e but it also can help repair
brain damage and protect the brain against
clotting garlic is a good blood thinner
then we have exercise which is going to support
more oxygen to the brain cells one last therapy
which i have done and i love is is the hyperbaric
oxygen therapy you should look into it if you
haven't heard about it and it can create some
serious improvement if you actually had a stroke
and you're trying to force oxygen deep into the
brain to repair it hey before you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to bulletproof your
immune system it's a free course i want you to
take it and here's why here's you here is your
environment everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment much
better by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today